[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in today's brief video we're
going to be discussing harry potter
professor minerva mcgonagall and one of
her most iconic lines
in the entire harry potter series i'm
going to be discussing its significance
and then having a go at a little theory
a door to his left flew open
and professor mcgonagall emerged from
her office looking grim
and slightly harassed what on earth are
you shouting about
potter she snapped as peeves cackled
gleefully and zoomed out of sight
why aren't you in class i've been sent
to see you said harry
stiffly sent what do you mean scent
he held out the note from professor
umbridge professor mcgonagall took it
from him
frowning slit it open with a tap of her
wand
stretched it out and began to read her
eyes zoomed from side to side
behind their square spectacles as she
read what umbridge had written
and with each line they became narrower
come in here potter
well said professor mcgonagall rounding
on him
is it true is what true harry asked
rather more aggressively than he had
intended
professor he added in an attempt to
sound more polite
is it true that you shouted at professor
umbridge yes said harry
you called her a liar yes you told her
he who must not be named is back
yes professor mcgonagall sat down behind
her desk frowning at harry
then she said have a biscuit potter have
what
have a biscuit she repeated impatiently
indicating a tartan tin
lying on top of one of the piles of
papers on her desk and sit down
now this is such an important line
because of the undertones that it
conveys
at this point in time umbridge is
beginning to rise to power
and she's a peer of mcgonagall's someone
that harry and all of the other students
are meant to respect it's the standard
teacher teacher-student relationship
ultimately in this sort of dynamic
insolence is not tolerated from the
student
but in this particular case mcgonagall
clearly appears to side with harry
mcgonagall should be disciplining harry
for talking back to umbridge
but instead of punishing him she ends up
offering him a biscuit
a courtesy that one would not expect
during formal punishment
you see mcgonagall's lack of enthusiasm
to punish harry
comes from a place of disliking umbridge
herself she knows that umbridge is nuts
and ultimately she trusts the word of
harry and dumbledore over her
this is precisely why harry is offered a
biscuit this event
is also significant because mcgonagall
was someone that took her job
very seriously the fact that she was
able to act against
traditional rules speaks volumes to how
much she distrusted umbridge
but now on to the important question
what kind of biscuit did mcgonagall
offer harry i think the key to this
answer is in the tin
as a tartan tin is specifically
referenced
we also know that mcgonagall is scottish
and grew up in
scotland which means that she's more
than likely accustomed to traditional
scottish treats
biscuits included so what scottish comes
in a tartan tin
you might ask that's right walker's
scottish shortbread
if you aren't aware shortbread is a
traditional scottish biscuit
usually made from one part white sugar
two parts butter
and either three parts oat flour or four
parts plain wheat flour
it's a scottish staple and i think that
this is a very compelling argument
for the specific biscuit that harry was
offered at this point in time
however this theory does fall to pieces
as
just seven chapters later in chapter 19
of the order of the phoenix
it is revealed that the cookie offered
to harry was in fact a
ginger newt a parody of the real-life
biscuit gingernut
we know this because of the following
line provoked you
shouted professor mcgonagall slamming a
fist onto her desk
so that her tartan tin slid sideways off
it and burst open
littering the floor with ginger newts
he'd just lost hadn't he
and that's it for this video did you
guys already know the type of biscuits
offered to harry
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
i'm sure we're all going to be very good
friends